[MUSIC PLAYING]
SARAH-JANE LESLIE: I think
it's fantastic to recognize
students who are taking
risks with their dissertation
projects.
Students who are thinking
outside of the box.
And I think that's
one special thing
that the Jacobus Prize allows
us to recognize at Princeton.
ADAM LERNER: I'm Adam Lerner.
I'm a graduate student
working at the intersection
of philosophy and
cognitive science.
And my dissertation is on the
role of empathy and ethics.
SARAH-JANE LESLIE: Adam isn't
afraid to stake out positions
that are challenging to people.
He's not afraid to occupy
controversial areas
of the intellectual terrain.
And he's also -- never hesitates
to employ the most cutting-edge
or innovative techniques
in order to test those.
ADAM LERNER: This is a lemon.
And, OK, so probably, if
you're like most people,
when you saw me bite into
that lemon, your mouth
itself puckered.
You might have even felt some
saliva pooling into your mouth.
That may not have
happened to you,
but it happens to lots
of people when they see
another person eating a lemon.
And that is -- you
were simulating
what it's like to eat
a lemon, automatically.
You didn't have to try;
it was just automatic.
So that's one way in which you
might simulate someone else's
experience.
Another is if you see
someone cutting a lemon,
and they slip and
accidentally cut their finger.
You might withdraw
your own finger
as if you had cut your
finger and even wince.
You're simulating what it's
like to cut your finger.
It doesn't feel exactly the same
way as cutting your own finger,
but it's a faint echo of
the pain you would feel
if you cut your own finger.
So that's an
example of, sort of,
automatic mirroring
form of empathy
where you automatically
simulate the experience
of the other person.
But there are other
forms of empathy
that are more deliberate.
So you can read a novel
and try to imagine
what it's like to be someone --
to be the protagonist.
You can also use
virtual reality devices
to put yourself in the
shoes of another person,
to imagine what it's like
to be a refugee fleeing
from war, to imagine what it's
like to be an animal raised
on a factory farm.
These are all ways you
can empathize deliberately
with other people, or beings
in general, such as animals.
And these are all different
forms of simulating or sharing
other people's mental lives.
And, I think, that's
the kind of empathy
that I investigate
in my dissertation.
[MUSIC PLAYING]